i was briefly engaged married for for a
minute but i'm single now and i wish
that somebody uh would have given me
this advice
years ago so here's advice
um
to the couples out there thinking about
getting married some advice to all you
couples out there thinking of getting
married i see that my boy caleb box is
here my dude he just got engaged so i
wonder if he's you know focusing on
these types of questions so we just went
from nfts we'll get to a little
something more solid here's financial
advice for the couples out there for the
lovebirds so when thinking of marriage
you know obviously you think of the
engagement then you think of the
bachelor parties and the bachelorette
parties and the wedding and then the
party and then the dance and then the
groom and then the this and then that
then the honeymoon and then the kids and
but when all the dust settles you get
back to the real world right and you
have to get back to life so here are
three questions to ask
each other before marriage david you
want to cue this one up here we go buddy
number one first
first question
what's your squad what's your credit
score
first question what's your credit score
first date first first date how are you
doing my name's david what's your credit
what's your credit score what are you
doing okay
so obviously you want to marry someone
who's pretty serious about you know
their financial well-being and they're
making their payments on time and
they're not
um taking on too much debt
um but if their credit score is crazy
low like in the 600s or the 500
something ridiculously low you're gonna
want to know why
right
so
as a famous
rapper has once said if the credit score
low you know they a hoe
this could be a he or she
this could be a he or she thing
okay
hopefully your credit score isn't too
low low hello
shout out to flowrider right there
anyway so number one if you're gonna get
married find out what your soon-to-be
spouse's credit score is okay number two
how much debt do you have this is a
probably an aggressive approach on the
first date
but before you step down the the aisle
maybe this is something that you want to
ask your future spouse
what kind of debt you got going on oh
you've got uh you've got uh 50 grand in
credit card debt and 100 grand in
student loan debt and you got cars and
and uh you've got consumer loans and
you've got macy's cards and uh you've
got all this uh you got taxed out you so
you owe three hundred dollars
this is uh
this this
that'd be good to know up front this
woman nursed you back to health from a
terrible car accident she taught you how
to walk again but she owes a little bit
of student loans right
you know it's like look you tell them
look i don't care
about your exes i don't care who you
dated before
i don't care if you got a kid i don't
care what's your credit score what's
your credit score and how much debt do
you have i need to know
okay how much debt you got so and oh and
just for the record
what's the credit score i'm sorry what's
the debt and what's the interest rate
and what's the amount those three things
what's the debt
what's the amount of debt and what's the
interest rate so as an example all right
so you owe 50 grand in student loans all
right cool four percent interest rate
five it's nothing crazy or hold on uh
you got credit cards that are you're
paying uh 24 and you own 60 you know you
own 40 grand in credit cards
what are you doing what are you doing
are you funding a lifestyle that you
can't afford this is going to get a
little slippery out there so as they
always say
right
if they owe a lot
drop them like it's hot wow yeah
nobody's nobody says that nobody says
that but these are the ones we're
dropping we're dropping some gems out
there
uh and also
if they owe too much
now you got to pay for lunch
these are things that are just inspiring
shout out to marcelo out there for
dropping these bombs out here but those
are the truth bombs the credit score is
low they might be a hope
if they owe a lot drop them like it's
hot
and if they owe too much
now you've got to pay for lunch that's a
song here there's a little thing that's
save that money remix right there by
your boy right here all right and number
three
right we talked about number one what's
your credit score number two how much
debt do you have number three what are
your financial goals this is a little
more serious of a topic so let's let's
let's reel it in no bring it back no no
rap lyrics on this one
everything starts with dreams and your
goals everything starts with dreams and
goals
and then
you got to have a plan
to match your dreams and your goals so
what do you want to accomplish right and
does your future
spouses goals
align or they conflict with what your
goals are so maybe you want to save up
to buy a house
and your you know future wife is more
concerned about balling out at the mall
you know maybe you want to buy a rental
property and your girl just you know
wants to sit around all day future goals
are important so
that would be a problem so those are the
big three things that this article says
you need to focus on before getting
married number one what's your credit
score number two how much debt do you
have number three what are your overall
financial goals respect to you so the
big takeaway here is this don't be
afraid to ask the tough questions it
definitely might be uncomfortable in the
short term
but in the long term i think we can all
agree this is definitely a worthy
conversation and worth in the long run
thoughts
oh um
tough i mean i agree definitely know
your partner's financial situation
before you get in there and you know
propose and make do the big decision
yeah but at the same time sauce what is
love nowadays honey i love you perfect
spouse but you owe a little too much for
me
okay next next all right well look
here's what i'd say to that love
butterflies
you know
feeling good it's it's it's great it's
awesome in the beginning
but then reality sets in yeah you got
bills to pay yeah it's lovely you got a
mortgage and you got kids
right
love might not pay the bills is the
bottom line obviously you want to have
love
but i also kind of want to have your
[ __ ] together
it's a tough decision to make but i i
agree with these rights
we got our guy manny gigi over here says
marriage
is a team
for sure
if you ever see anything regarding pat
and anything he does at php respect to
the folks out there this other company
php
half the people in the company are like
couples
and there's couples crushing it the
sapalas the vargas's
um
ricky and erica oh my god
jose and marlene guyton like they're
just couples that are doing their thing
so that's something that i think that
would be a great example for other
people out there like you don't
obviously have to work in the same field
you might be a
you know production coordinator and your
girl might be a musician or you might be
a lawyer and your girl might be a
bartender whatever it is just make sure
you're on the same team and you have
goals that you're looking to accomplish
and you're on the same page yeah
yes i agree there we go
um
so that's that those are the big three
things that you should ask your future
spouse before
marriage is money all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken